so we'll jump right in I'm kind of
assuming that hopefully everybody here
is more of a Python person than they are
an hour person because I'm kind of going
to go through some of the basics yeah
the idea here is uh at least whenever I
started looking at art and everything
it's kind of a foreign language it
become from something else some of the
things will kind of drive you nuts at
first personally I love language the
more I got into it it took a little bit
of time but even with ten years of
experience in Python I still find that a
lot of times that I'm doing exploratory
data analysis are just tends to fit my
mind a little bit better and I get
things done faster so that's one of the
reasons why I kind of advocate for we're
using both so so let me just you know go
through some of the reasons because I'm
hoping I can I also kind of convince
some of you I'm assuming some of you
were coming in here as skeptics and
maybe I'll go through at least a handful
the reasons why I like using it so first
off or have probably first and foremost
its data centric I mean this language
was literally created for doing data
analysis pythons obviously more
general-purpose and it's a fantastic
language for all that okay so yeah I
mean you know Python is a great language
for general-purpose computing and it's
becoming better and better and better
every day with all the PI data
Sify packages and everything and it is a
fantastic language for actually doing
data analysis but I still feel like you
know you have a language that is
essentially a DSL a domain-specific
language for data analysis so it just
seems to fit right another is it has
tons of battle-tested high-quality
packages that I mean you know this is a
language for statisticians so of course
anything that you would ever want to do
any sort of analysis you don't want to
do is going to be somewhere in there so
having access to all of those is going
to be a really nice toolset for you even
coming from the Python side mm-hmm and
will actually see a little bit later on
how to actually pull those two things
together towards the very end so um you
know it's data visualization
capabilities and I'm gonna go with
ggplot2 here is just you know I think
hands down the best you know it's it
uses something called the grammar of
graphics
and that really makes all the difference
to me it basically wraps up in a very
nice way kind of a language that you use
to interact with your data in a visual
you know visual way it takes a little
bit longer to get used to I mean
honestly if you come into our and you
use plot you're going to get something
up and running faster but I think a
little bit of investment in ggplot2 and
you'll have something that you know just
it makes it so much easier to actually
do your data visualization and just
reason about what you want to visualize
so and this is also coming from somebody
who did a you know it's like a no Riley
course on matplotlib so even though a
Python fan and I like matplotlib and
it's fantastic I still find ggplot2 a
much easier you know library to use for
visualization okay now this one's
probably my most controversial statement
I guess but personally I feel like it
just feels like it's more it fits more
naturally with data are as a functional
language so if you're coming from
you know Python this is going to seem a
little foreign to you but you know the
idea of actually taking a bunch of
functions and kind of pipelining them
together in a way that transforms your
data so you have this kind of pipeline
flow of data all the way to the end just
seems much more natural to me and the
libraries things like deep liar and
magnet reader it's like are basically
built up to allow you to do that and the
fact that R is also a very malleable
language it allows you to create
domain-specific languages within it just
makes it so much simpler I think and
just more intuitive in your mind once
you start working with it
hmm so these are going beyond just
basically the data aspects of it but
it's an interesting language once I got
past the blue misses it blemishes that I
first came across in the language which
will go over here and hopefully I will
get you past and you can immediately go
into just enjoying the language it's
actually really interesting if you're
into languages you've probably been into
Lisp at least at one point in time and
this is a heavily Lisp inspired language
which makes it really cool in my opinion
um you know you'll you'll see that the
language is like I said it's actually a
very malleable language you have you
know something that's kind of equal to
Lisp macros inside of here so you know
it's just a cool language to learn just
expanding your mind you know it's like
that perspective and then finally I
would say it can be a good source of
ideas for the Python community so once
you get in here and start playing around
some of the things that are has one of
the things I love is that it has
something called data packages so people
will just take a you know a bunch of
data that they find interesting they'll
put it into a package and now you just
import it like any other library and you
have access to all the data it's in a
nice data frame you have all the
documentation on all the variable names
and everything right there in your
actual IDE it's just so much easier to
work with I'd love to see more like that
and where that stuff come over to Python
as I mentioned the ggplot2 library is
just fantastic so that's a good source
of inspiration and then we'll see a
little bit later the IDE that they have
for our studio which is just hands down
still the best for interactive analysis
so in addition to that you know just
learning art is gonna open up a whole
new world of resources for you and if
some of the best books out there on data
science my favorite is the introduction
to statistical learning which I'm still
kind of working my way through is once
you learn art they'll basically be there
for you to pick up so by not knowing are
you kind of shutting off like 50% of the
world of knowledge out there as far as
data science goes and then we get to the
art studio suite of tools so the art
studio a company have sent some
fantastic work I mean they have probably
hands down the best tools that you can
get the our Studio IDE would see down
here in the bottom right corner is a
probably the best thing that you can get
for like interacting with your data I
know there's spider on the Python side
and I think there's a rodeo one that I
think is now kind of defunct maybe I
haven't seen an update on it in like 11
months or so and they were kind of
trying to compete with this but I
haven't seen anything come close just
yet in addition to that you have things
like our markdown our notebooks which
you know make it easy to do reproducible
research and actually package it up and
send it off to whoever you need to I
think it's actually easier to do our
markdown and send a you know an actual
nice document off to the cenotes your
c-suite throw it every night as opposed
to like you know the jupiter notebook
and then you have things like shiny that
allow you to do these really interactive
dashboards that are fantastic and you
know it's the least disliked language
you know in the world right now
according to satisfaction David Robinson
is stackoverflow so there you go there's
a reason people don't hate it that much
so those are all my reasons for why you
need to learn are so hopefully
everybody's now like oh my god I can't
wait to get into this and everything so
now I'm gonna get you past the barriers
that I had whenever I got into art so
what you need to know as a Python
developer so first off dots and dollar
signs this thing drove me nuts the very
first time you look at a piece of our
code which you will probably see is
something dot something or whatever and
you will be thinking to yourself oh
that's an object and a method call that
is not R is a functional language and in
fact the legal characters for function
names include letters numbers
underscores Israel pretty normal and
dots this one drives me nuts it's about
one of the it's second to the the dollar
sign is the ugliest thing in the
language as far as I'm concerned so if
you look at a function like data dot
frame this is actually a function call
not a not an object in method call so
you notice that you also see a couple
more in there you see row dot name check
dot rows so this has been a pretty
long-standing common practice that
you're going to run into this just about
everywhere you look it's all over base R
and it's no longer really suggested that
you use dots in your names and we'll
talk a little bit about that when we get
into the object-oriented system but um
also notice you see strings as factors
down there as a bottom and camelcase
so you can see that even base r can't
figure out what the hell they want to do
it is one of the things that will drive
you crazy is that no one really has come
up with the way that they want to do all
this stuff so there is a Google style
guide and there's a tidy verse style
guide I would suggest looking at those
those do suggest underscores for
everything so that's a good place to
look to make sure your code it doesn't
drive you as nuts as some of the other
code drives me
so if dot if dots don't actually do
anything if they're just part of the
name then how do you actually access the
attributes inside of an object or
whatever well first remember that
there's you know objects act a little
bit differently because functional
language so you're not gonna be
accessing methods yeah you know in some
cases but we won't get into that but
way you do have the ability to index and
get attribute access through these two
operators II have a dollar sign and
double brackets so we'll create an
object this is my first example and in
our almost everything almost every
object is going to be a list
Alissa's just basically a heterogeneous
coupling of data so you have all the
different data types you want there's
also a vector which is a homogeneous
type which we'll see that a little bit
but here is my object representing the
yeah when I started LinkedIn and we want
to get access to everything and we can
use the you know the dollar sign or the
double brackets to do so now notice I'm
pulling in a library called glue and
that's another thing it drives me nuts
the string manipulation kind of in R is
not the best you know right off the door
so glue is a nice tidy verse package
that provides streaming manipulation and
interpolation so you can see here it's
starting to look a little bit more like
what we would normally work with so and
I'm just basically calling me dollar
first-name to get the first name and
then the double brackets gets you the
second value last name and notice that R
is one indexed that may also drive you
nuts
so right so this is good we're getting
all the normally awful stuff out of the
door right now you will come out of here
and be like okay who I've seen the worst
these are all the things that made me
leave and come back and leave and come
back you know all right so those are
some of the the first pieces but
assignment operators so this is another
one that oh the first time you see that
error you're probably gonna be like what
the heck is that
well it's assignment so basically the
arrow is kind of a holdover from the API
APL language R is heavily influenced by
both Lisp and APL basically the equal
sign was used for testing qualities so
they had to come up with something
different and didn't think of double
equals I guess but uh
the arrow is there so you can pretty
much use equal ever since 2001 it's been
there but I think most style guides
prefer that you don't so you should
probably stick with the left arrow also
there's right arrow equivalents of this
so if you actually do like a nice
pipeline flow of all your data being
filtered you can actually pipe it out at
the very end to a variable if you
which may make it hard to read but it's
nice to have if you're doing interactive
work but anyway that's a set point so
let's take a look at an example of how
this works because there is a subtle
difference between the arrow and the
equal sign and that's one of the reasons
why they suggest you use the arrow and
if we take a look at our function
signature for the mean function it
basically takes an X variable and then a
bunch of other stuff but we don't we're
not really concerned about that so let's
take a look at using the equal sign
whenever you're passing in an argument
so here I'm going to call the mean
function I'm going to pass in a
basically a vector of you know numbers
randomly selected from a uniform
distribution between 0 and 1 and we're
going to pass that in we're gonna get an
average of that now I'm gonna I'm using
the local thing here because I basically
don't want to introduce new variables
into the global environment so you can
kind of ignore that but just trying to
keep things clean in my in my notebook
so anyway we call that and this works
perfectly if we call print on LS which
the LS function will just give you all
the actual variables and everything that
are in your current environment we
noticed that there's nothing there which
is what you'd expect whenever you're
passing in an argument right if you try
to basically use the arrow the same way
that you would use the equal sign here
that's not the case basically the arrow
is going to first set the Y variable in
the local environment and then it's
gonna pass that variable into the mean
function and set it equal to the very
first argument so mean still works
doesn't blow up if this were the equal
sign it would blow up because it would
basically be telling you there is no
such thing as a Y argument no so yeah
it's a little bit weird it's best if you
just stick with the arrow and you know
views equals only for the arguments
passing in or whatever it and that just
makes your code a little bit easier
understand and cleaner and there's also
the deep assignment operator so the
double arrow that we saw a little bit
ago so a close thing I can think of in
Python world is probably the global
keyword and essentially this just allows
you to modify variables up the the call
stack so in in environments outside of
it so if you look at I guess call sex
bed words so if you look at it it will
search the lexical stack of all your
so each environment up until finally
finds one that matches and then it'll
actually change that where you usually
see this used is uh closures so here
I've created a function a closure that
basically creates an AI iterator
variable and it's going to return a
function that just increments that
variable by some offset so the double
arrow gives me access to the enclosing
environments variable I so I'm going to
call that I instantly instantly call
with the number two so we're going to
increment by two and then I just loop
through and show you how it works or
whatever so so you're starting to get
some stuff it looks a little bit
JavaScript to here I guess so this is
one that I said you know those are kind
of the more visual blemishes I guess or
whatever this is one that actually kind
of drove me nuts whenever I first got
into it and it makes perfect sense in
our everything is a vector I mean you
basically have a language whose main
purpose is dealing with data right so
data is plural typically so everything
in our is plural as well you can see
that by this example we're gonna create
a new numbers variable then we're gonna
set it equal to the number 42 if I call
length on that number I get back a 1 so
it's actually a vector of numbers and if
I do a type of and now see all vectors
in in are basically defined by the type
of their underlying data so double is
basically underlying data here so we get
back a type of that type of should only
really work on vectors and then this is
what I really love so we actually take
the number itself 42 and we'll actually
index it will get back the number 42 so
this allows us to do yeah this is
actually just a show you that it is a
vector of 1 so if you try to index 2 you
get nothing
this allows us to do some really weird
stuff like this so we have a vector of
four numbers and then we just basically
continue to one index do this C infinity
respect and then this is the reason
though why things like this
automatically work in our so basically
everything is vectorized if we take that
vector that we just made and run the
modulo operation on it it just
automatically runs it on everything it
returns back to a subjective all the
modded number
so this is one of the things that makes
you know using our for data manipulation
just ten times easier it's just
automatically gonna do what you think it
should do yes
all right so those are most of the
things that I consider to be like yes
like you need to get past it to kind of
enjoy the language a little bit so now
let's just kind of go into some of the
things you need to understand about the
language to really use it so as I
mentioned our is functional it has
first-class functions higher-order
functions lambdas and closures it allows
a lot of computing on the actual
language itself and it attempts to be
pure and I'm going to show you an
example of that this is a little more
involved example and I'm using the prior
library which is another one from Hadley
with them you're gonna hear his name
over and over again if you get into our
and essentially what that allows you to
do it's kind of a learning which allows
you to kind of rip into the insides of
the language and just introspect a
little bit more so what I'm gonna do
here is I'm gonna create a new list
object and I'm gonna show you how the
copy on modify versus you know modify in
place works so I create my new object X
and again doing this inside of local and
this is a little bit different because
inside of Jupiter and our studio they
tend to add another reference to objects
so this is one way I can get away with
that not happening so I'm gonna print
out the number of references and notice
there's one and I'm gonna basically
print out the address I'm gonna modify
that that variable that I just created
so that objects I'm gonna change it to
the name that I prefer and then we're
gonna print that again and notice the
addresses are exactly the same so
whatever there's only one reference ours
gonna try to be faster for you it's
gonna try to do the right thing it's
gonna modify in place when I increase
the reference count so now I create
another variable Y and I set that equal
to X and I can see that now I have two
references now its gonna try to be a lot
more pure it's basically gonna do
everything copy on a copy I'll modify so
if I change my name to my full name
notice whenever I print it out this time
it actually made a full copy of the
object and saved it back as X so you're
gonna actually run into this is one of
the reasons why are tends to be a little
bit slower than a lot of other languages
it's arguable that it could be faster
because you know closure with a J has
actually shown you how to do that but
its current
imitation this is a large reason why
it's actually slow so when you start
getting into this language and want to
make it faster if you want to still use
our you're gonna have to learn how this
copy of modify works and how to actually
am on you know avoid that but this is
one the reasons why I kind of look at
our is great for EDA but maybe it's time
to move over to Python once you start
getting into 1e
something a little faster alright so if
you're into Python you are obviously
going to be into object-oriented
programming so you're probably gonna be
wondering well how do you do that in a
functional language and well because you
know R is functional it actually has
several different systems for doing oo P
and we can see you can see each of those
but first let's look at a couple of
different styles so there's two
different styles that the oob systems
tend to have so one is an encapsulated
style and that's typically what we
normally see where methods actually
belong to objects so you have classes
all kind of stuff and the other one is a
functional style and if you've actually
gotten into Lisp you've probably seen
something it looks a lot like this thing
it's called class the common list of
object system but essentially you have
methods that will belong to other
functions called generics and we'll see
an example of this in a little bit but
first let's go through some of the just
real quick some of the actual object
oriented systems that you have first is
s3 which is a functional system this
one's important to know and this one's
the one we're gonna go through at least
a little bit to give you some
understanding because it's used all
throughout besar and this is also the
reason why you no longer use dots in
your variable names but we'll see that
in a second there's s4 which is also a
functional system it's pretty much like
s3 it's much more formal s3 is very
conventional it's about as loose loosely
done as you can possibly do and still
have some sort of system whatever right
so we'll see how it works in a second
there's RC which is an encapsulated
system so this is getting closer to what
we're used to in most most
object-oriented languages and the main
reason for using this one typically is
for getting past ours copy on modify
semantics so the thing that we just
spoke about and everything so we will
see see that a little later and r6 is an
encapsulated system
and it's similar it's similar to our see
but it's a lighter white tends to avoid
a lot of problems that RC has by relying
on the s4 system and the main reason for
I really going over this is because it
tends to be used in a lot of the the
tiny vers packages so you will see that
if you start to get into that the only
one that we're gonna look at today
though is the s3 system so as I
mentioned it's very informal it relies
pretty much 100% on convention so it's
it has methods that are better functions
that basically implement the class
specific behavior and then you have
generic functions which are essentially
your dispatch methods they will look up
these methods and run them for you based
on an object's class attribute so this
is why I said it's very convention
oriented it's literally based on a
string on on your object so let's see an
example in are you have you have a class
or a type called a factor it's similar
to a category if you're in the Python
world or whatever so essentially it's
just categorical data so I'm going to
create a brand new vector of integers
and they have to be integers because
factors have to be integers so that's
why you see the one L here so here's my
do vector so if I print that out just
looks like a normal vector now if I go
through and I modify it first thing I
want to do is I'm gonna add a levels
attribute so that will define basically
the different categorical values that
you can get so in our case that we small
medium large and extra-large and then
going to add a class so I just literally
add a string factor and then I print and
notice the print is different it's like
now of a sudden I've changed the type of
this thing just by adding that and the
reason for that is if you look at this
print dot factor function so this is
actually the function that's being
called this is the method that we talked
about this is the class pacific behavior
that is behind factor the print function
that i called up there is actually the
generic function what it does is it
dispatches on the class factor and it
finds something that looks exactly like
this it literally looks for generic dot
class so this is why you don't want to
put dots in your names there's a very
good chance if you put them in there you
may actually plug yourself into the
object-oriented
system that comes in our so this is also
probably one of the bigger blemishes and
one that can get you in quite a lot of
trouble so underscores always so how do
you override behavior in s3 since this
is a convention you know a convention
oriented system it's super easy to
actually override behavior we're going
to basically subvert the current print
factor function with our own so we're
gonna grab a hold of the print dot
factor function we just looked at and
we're going to change it we're just
gonna add another print that you know
prints a string and again it's kind of
where we're calling the generic inside
of our you know our method or whatever
right so this is gonna the generic is
gonna look at what it gets as a string
and it's gonna call the print dot string
function for you so it starts to get a
little rabbit holy so anyway we will
call the old print factor function that
we captured and just pass in all of the
data the dot dot dot is kind of the
equivalent to start start start clogs or
whatever so we'll call print on our
sizes function our data type that we had
earlier and notice that'll call our new
print dot factor function so we just
plugged ourselves in or override the
existing behavior in the system and then
we'll just look real quick at creating a
class so here's my me object that I
created earlier again I'm gonna just add
my class you know attribute to it so I'm
gonna call it an employee class and then
I want to create my new function print
that employee and it's just basically
gonna pull in the statement from earlier
to print myself out and then when I call
the generic function on me it will the
system goes through finds the generic
class so print dot employee and calls
that function for me there you go art is
object-oriented system in a nutshell oh
man five minutes and I have still have
like non-standard evaluation so this is
one of the more fun parts of our
whatever is non-standard evaluation are
actually gives you direct access to the
code itself that actually you know
calculates the value of the values that
are being passed into a function so here
we have the mean function again and
first off everything in our is lazy so
that's one of the reasons why this can
happen what I call the mean function I
pass
just a vector of values and then notice
I'm passing in this you this variable it
just does not exist at all and I'm
passing it in with an X plus y X plus y
does not exist either but this this
never computes that it never runs
because I never used that data and
Python this would blow up it would say X
doesn't exist why does it exist whatever
yeah but here it will runs perfectly
fine this allows you to do some weird
stuff like capture the arguments so
here's a print expression function that
I've created where it'll take an
expression take a bunch of different
variables it's gonna capture that
expression that's what the substitute
call does the list just basically turns
your list of optional variables into a
list object and then eval is going to
evaluate the expression that we captured
in the context of the list object that I
just created so whenever we call print
expression X plus y I pass it in x and y
values and now those things are going to
basically show up whenever I call
evaluate because it's you know I'm
changing the context of where this thing
is being evaluated and I can actually
print out the function itself the code
that I had to by calling deep horse
which basically takes the abstract
syntax tree that I grabbed earlier was
substitute and turns it back into the
code so that's cool stuff and this is
why things like this works really well
so whenever you call ggplot you know the
ggplot2 you know library here you're
actually calling it and notice I'm
passing in x and y values first off I
don't have quotes around HP and mpg and
it's not blowing up those aren't
variables those are actual names and
things that I want second it's actually
grabbing those and using those as the x
and y value axes label so it's actually
thinking a lot of it a lot of this stuff
a headed for you and doing it for you
all right so trying to cuz I wanted to
go to one more piece hopefully which is
at least lets you look at this one
notebook
so this is our pi/2 this is where it
really kind of plugs everything back in
right so now you do all of your analysis
and jupiter with python pythons is great
for you know general-purpose programming
so you can do all of your data
manipulation everything up front to
clean your data and then if you happen
to have like a function in our that
doesn't exist in in a you know python
you can just run it through so our pi/2
actually has some our magic and if you
notice i'm basically pulling in a data
set
from scikit-learn it's the Boston
housing prices or whatever I turn that
into a data frame and then I have this
art magic here on on sell for where - I
says what input D F I give it the data
frame and then I basically call my GG
plot functions on here and I get a nice
you know it's like it'll basically turn
that data frame in Python into a data
frame and R for me automatically and I
can do whatever I want with it
and then next is even better I can
actually use the linear regression
function inside of our and perform a
linear regression on it and notice the -
oh here at the top so now I'm passing
that model back out to Python and it
just automatically translates it back
into a model object over here which you
can actually see the linear regression
that I just ran or whatever sighs all
right so that's probably all my rights
though anyway that's that's everything I
have so questions anything hopefully I
can make you all to use all does anybody
hear me
[Applause]
yep for this last bit here I might have
not been paying attention at the top
where do you have to sort of call
anything specific to use this or is this
built into Jupiter it's so you basically
once you install the the R Phi to
package in pandas
there's you'll get this load external
whatever so once you call that you have
everything you need and then it's just a
matter of calling the our magicks
although I think they don't call it our
magicks anymore on the documentation
yeah that's it super simple so I Chinese
great for putting up a you know running
a function putting up a GG plots is
there are any cran packages that'll do
things like run some R code as a web
service well I mean you know you could
argue that if you use the R studio like
professional server and shiny that you
might have something like that but I
yeah I mean that that's where I'm kind
of I mean that's my feeling is like you
know I use R for a lot of the
data analysis and everything and that's
when I start to switch over to Python
Python is just great at that level
whatever so right oh yeah down here so I
wanted to ask about the substitute
function I noticed that you used it in
one of your functions there and it it
kind of confuses me I don't understand
why you can't just can you just grab
parameters from the from the function do
you have to use substitute yeah well
yeah there's there's a couple of
different functions there's quote is
another one which you know is like is
kind of similar but it just grabs
exactly the expression you pass them but
substitutes kind of necessary so
essentially you have this object called
a promise or whatever in in R or
whatever is basically what each of these
values are and the moment you try to
touch that promise it's automatically
going to evaluate substitute is just the
one way that you can keep that prevent
that from happening if you call
substitute on the promise object then it
instantly turns into an abstract syntax
tree and then you can do whatever you
want with it after that but before that
anything anytime you touch it it's just
automatically gonna eval so that makes
sense
yeah promises are a little deep magic I
tried to find some way that I could
actually show you a promise but
everything that I read was like okay you
just don't have access to it at the at
the console level or II thought that
it's kind of like more under the hood
and once you touch it it's gone and
chris has graciously offered to take
questions outside in the hallway to
afterwards so if you have any specific
ones you can ask him any other questions
here that is what I'm gonna have all
this stuff up on my github account and
everything so you can grab everything
and I have a I did have something on
virtual environments that I was going to
show but I I'm gonna turn that as to a
couple of blog posts before they in the
week so so there's that too one more
question what is it good oh yes sorry
see Roch I should probably check and
just make sure that is my github account
yeah that's it that's usually what I go
with whenever I can find it but
sometimes somebody steals approach sorry
last question um what is the good
starting point for Python users to start
using learning are how did you start how
did I start so I basically had an
assignment at work where I needed to I
needed to come up with like a KPI or
whatever for so we do hiring and
everything so I needed to come up with
some sort of measurement for interviewer
fairness so basically how much each
person is sharing the load of doing
interviews and I started playing around
with Python because that's what I knew
best and everything but the main thing
that I had was I needed to turn in
something to you know manager like three
levels above me or whatever right so I
needed like a PDF and our markdown is
just you know hands down the best or
whatever it's just so easy to turn it
into that so I started playing around
with our markdown and on our studio and
in our notebooks as well our notebooks
are also fantastic for like sharing and
everything so I could basically give
somebody an HTML document and it
actually has the code embedded in it you
have a button that you click and it
downloads and you know those are
basically my entrance into it and
started playing around with it from
there and then advanced are from heavily
with them it's the best book yeah thank
you so much Chris and of thanks
everybody
[Applause]